all right and hello to the new followers
on Twitter as well Twitter bugs and
thanks again for those that are
continual retweet errs very cool so
we're gonna enter the French defence
what what variation of the French ah
black says no actually this is a quick
transposition to a benoni let's develop
I need to defend my pawn on e4 these
guys you might regard as counterparts
that are both the fighting for the same
central squares nights on dark control
light it's the light squares in the
center that they're watching out for so
night here that it could be an eventual
pin I'm going to just stop that all
together right now so play h3 Knight f3
I have a space advantage because of this
pond planted on black side so let me
follow through swing the bat all the way
and what else where does my light square
Bishop want to Bing I think just e to
should I develop my light square Bishop
bow or my dark square Bishop actually
I'm gonna go out my light square Bishop
right here I'm a bit reluctant to play
I'm going to play here right now I want
to I want to watch out for this because
of the pressure on both d5 Andy for what
I was saying earlier is I'm a bit
reluctant to develop my bishop to f4
because of potential pawn structure
changes and in this case it would be
coming with tempo so I'd really like to
maybe avoid that if possible now there's
going to be a lot of minor pieces
beating up at my d5 pawn mmm I guess I'm
going to have to support it with Bishop
c4 and I'm really starting to wonder if
I should have initially developed my
light square Bishop there mmm not so
sure another move I could be doing is
actually Queen to d3 and I think I'm
going to go with that right now and will
actually hang on I could take here that
night is still around to watch it can I
actually put more fuel on it mmm might
be something to that takes takes night
here the probably a d5 push every piece
is watching over them what a pain
alright well let me do this still not
quite sure what I want to do my dark
square Bishop and I think this is a good
square for the Queen so let me do it if
the rook plays here it becomes a bit
more appealing to maybe run with this
night g5 move seeing how f seven would
be weakened as a result of the rook move
um okay now I got to watch out for b5
maybe I should actually commit my darks
for a bishop I want to probably get I
should probably do that right yeah let's
let's go with it okay so there could be
a structure change then black will be
looking to play on this side of the
board the actually anniela here's
another another feature of the Queen
move she's she's watching out for an
eventual f5 should the structure change
with pond here and I'm wondering if I
should back my bishop up voluntarily mmm
pawn push is that going to be played or
actually this could get really really
violent really quick in fact right now
maybe I could push or take and then push
Wow pawn takes Knight captures actually
i would give give me this square if that
happens pawn takes Knight takes i have
this square available pawn takes pawn
takes this file opens up for the rook
maybe I need to make one more move let
me do this move actually cuz now I'm
threatening to win this pawn with takes
and then I have a three pieces on it
might be seeing something happen here
very shortly now a good question is what
happens if e takes D how do I recapture
ok the my opponents going in reverse and
I think that now is actually good time
to open it up however if I take here pon
recaptures the bishops getting hit so
maybe I retreat my bishop first or play
here and open the position up on push
takes takes takes takes this rook is
undefended in those lines to do it the
space advantage and once there is a
disconnect this is another reason why
I'm going to strike in the center it's
because there they are the uncoordinated
side this night can't be too comfortable
being on the back rank and these these
rooks again a disconnect potential for
the rook being unprotected if there's a
series of exchanges on d5 so big
decision here loss of material loss of a
pond could translate into the loss of
the game one wrong move one one misstep
and that could be TKO
ok
two-minute warning for Team Black a lot
of tension when there is possibilities
for multiple pond structures to come
about that's usually a time to really be
going into a think tank huh now that's
interesting what about night here hmm
what's the scoop I'm down on time now
should I take here first Wow takes man i
can't forget this out we take their
first action oh yes definitely right
because i have a night an ensuing night
move right here hitting the Queen and
then maybe coming here or something if
the bishop takes maybe I have night g5
maybe look at the end of it all I mean I
could end up having an active rook or
something and this rook is still needing
some work before it could contribute so
let's see what is the big plan here
one minute to figure out all these
complications it's not going to happen
right we're both going to have to fly
we're both going to have to go real
quick here I don't know what the best
move is my opponent disconnect Oh are
they going to move it all ah there's
only 34 seconds this is a ton of time to
be spending right here black is wanting
to win got to go quick okay night here
night here
night here and try that Bishop takes a
capture here mate threat ah this is
falling on the Queen take with check oh
hang on there's a mate year mate threat
don't you dare I would have got really
loud g2g two is on fire hang on what's
the best move Bishop takes Knight TKO um
how about Queen g3 and everybody's happy
wow what a slick move actually let me do
this it's defend because now threatening
Knight takes bishop ah that's a checker
ruski take the Queen and I'm going to
recapture with my pond so I'm on the
night at the end of it capture stuff
open it up on push and then promote an
in-betweener okay my bishops close to
trapped but I'm going to do this hit the
bishop on that Bishop to on the rook
this pretty moves no time ok good game
that got really really intense that
middle game right there let's back up
interesting I've seen that played before
where black pivots about with those
minor pieces and puts an incredible
amount of pressure on d5 I wonder if
there was another key move maybe
somewhere there that could have caused
me some problems let me flip the board
forgot about that one um so so far so
book right so for our so book I don't
know about my age three move but at
least keep in mind the the idea behind
it I have a space advantage sometimes
giving up this Bishop because it's tough
to maybe even get it working in this
structure it's expendable trade the
bishop for night and focus on keeping a
grip over these dark squares so hmm i
wonder if I wonder if he five was the
way to go like right here as soon as I
piled up on this I think in the ensuing
complications there's really we could
say at this point there's no way that
white could be anywhere soft with these
the I mean black is just playing on
three ranks right here and actually you
know well here you go actually all right
um here's a way to look at it right it's
it's three ranks that black is playing
on and I'm playing on 5 i'm fully
developed i have a flight square for my
king in fact this isn't important these
are maybe like little little hints to
let you know why maybe the night move is
not good because look at look at how
things are in favor for me I mean you
look a bit more long-term and you start
to realize whoa all major pieces are
still on the board in fact not even a
single capture has occurred just yet and
black doesn't have a flight square yeah
so if the position is going to be
opening up who do you think if you if
you're weighing the probability and
statistics of things here who do you
thinks maybe going to be able to
capitalize on the other so yeah and i
think my opponent is saying out that in
the chat right here
they're sending that 'if I've yeah maybe
a better idea you know I think you're
gonna have to go with that of course I
think you know what it could actually be
the case where whites response of let's
say capturing on this square and then
recapturing hit in the Queen and then
following up with like an f4 is probably
still good for white being down a minor
piece by having just this avalanche of
ponds right here in the center taking
away up all support points for the
Knights I think that would even be a
pretty good possibility which is all the
more appealing because of the Queen's
position how could take with the bishop
and then the night and beyond the Queen
you really don't give black a chance to
breathe with that small combination but
in any event maybe that was actually the
best try he five so yeah going backwards
is I guess asking for trouble so okee
five critical pawn moves critical pawn
moves